what i want to do in this video is think
about the difference between a line
segment
a line segment
a line
and a ray
and array and this is kind of the pure
geometrical versions of these of these
things and so line segment is actually
probably what most of us associate with
the line in our everyday lives so a line
segment is something just like that for
lack of a better word a straight line
but what why we call it a segment is
that it actually has a starting and a
stopping point so most of the lines that
we experience in our everyday reality
are actually line segments when we think
of it from a pure geometrical point of
view and i know i drew a little bit of a
curve here but this is supposed to be
completely straight but it's the line
segment the segment the segment is based
on the fact that it has a ending point
and a starting point or a starting point
and an ending point a line if you're
thinking about it in the pure geometric
sense of a line is
essentially it's it does not stop it
doesn't have a starting point and an
ending point it keeps going on forever
in both directions so a line would look
like this
a line
would look like this and to show that it
keeps on going on forever and in that
direction right over there we draw this
arrow and to keep showing that it goes
on forever in kind of the down left
direction we draw this hour right over
here so obviously you know i've never
encountered something that just keeps on
going straight forever
forever but in math that's the neat
thing about math we can think about
these abstract notions and so the
mathematical purest geometric sense of a
line is this straight thing that goes on
forever now array is something in
between array has a well-defined
starting point so that's its starting
point but then it just keeps on going on
forever so then so the ray might start
over here but then it just keeps on
going then it just keeps on going so
that right over there is array now that
out of the way let's actually try to do
the khan academy module on recognizing
the difference between line segments
lines and rays i think you'll find it
pretty straightforward based on on our
little classification right over here so
let me get the module
let me get the module going
let me
let me where did i put it
where did i put it there you go all
right so what is this thing right over
here well it has two arrows on both ends
so
it's implying that it goes on forever so
this is going to be a line
let's check our answer yeah it's a line
now it's taking some time oh correct
next question all right now what about
this thing well once again arrows on
both sides means that this thing is
going to go on forever in both
directions so once again it is a line
fair enough
let's do another one
here we have one arrow so it goes on
forever in this direction but it has a
well-defined starting point so it starts
there and then goes on forever and if
you remember that's what a ray is one
starting point but goes on forever
so it goes or one way to think about it
goes on forever in only one direction so
that is a ray
so let's do another question
this right over here you have a starting
point and an ending point or you could
call this the start point in the ending
point but it doesn't go on forever in
either direction so this right over here
is a line segment
there you go so hopefully that that that
gives you enough to to
work your way through this module and
you might notice when i did this when i
did this
model right here there is no video and
that's exactly what this video is it's
the video for this module